This video was made possible by ExpressVPN.
Start browsing the web securely with three
months free by going to expressvpn.com/wendover.
When you think of freight transport, the image
in your head might include massive container
ships, or mile-long trains, or enormous cargo
planes, but more than each of those, the transportation
method that carries the vast majority of the
world’s freight is trucks.
In most places, it’s not even close—by
value, they carry 73% of the US’ domestic
freight.
It is truly trucks that connect the world,
more than anything else.
Trucking fills a lot of roles from just daily
deliveries to urban households all the way
to cross-country treks bringing goods from
manufacturer to consumer.
It is that form, though—long-haul, over-the-road
trucking—that is most elusive.
These trucks are visible on the highways of
any country, but the infrastructure supporting
this transportation system hides in plain
sight.
When on the road, long-haul truckers live
and work in their trucks.
Of course their job is centered around sitting
behind the wheel, but the section behind that
is where they live.
Drivers are only allowed to drive a certain
number of hours at a time—in the US, it’s
11, in Europe, it’s 9, and in the rest of
the world it’s something similar to those
two.
Therefore, they need the facilities to live,
rest, and recreate when off the road in the
remaining hours of the day.
Most trucks have a cab just large enough for
a bed, TV, microwave, and a few other small
appliances.
They are typically intentionally minimalistic
because there is a trade-off between the size
and weight of the cab and how much freight
can be hauled.
This truly is a trade-off for the drivers,
mostly, as a big proportion of them in places
like the US actually own their truck themselves
and work for companies on a freelance basis.
That means they could decide to buy a rig
with a larger, more comfortable cab, but that
could make them less capable of hauling heavier
loads, which means less money.
Trucks are weight-restricted mostly to keep
the roads in decent condition.
The greater the weight, the greater the impact.
In the US, this maximum weight varies widely.
On most highways it’s 80,000 pounds or 36,000
kilograms, but this varies from state to state
all the way up to 164,000 pounds or 75,000
kilograms in Michigan.
Considering this variance, states will typically
have weigh stations near their borders on
major highways, as well as some spread out
throughout the state.
All trucks, except for some that have electric
systems allowing them to bypass, are required
to pull off onto massive scales to assure
they’re complying with the rules.
Using this opportunity, though, many weigh
stations have become far more technologically
advanced to assure safety and compliance.
For example, thermal cameras will take an
image of the wheels to assure the breaks are
working properly—if they’re too cold,
that could mean the breaks are not engaging,
if they’re too hot, that could mean they’re
engaging too much, in comparison to the other
breaks.
So, the weight issue, though, is why the average
rig looks just like this—a compact cab with
just the bare minimum of comforts.
The trade-off means that larger, extended
sleepers are only common with, for example,
long-haul moving trucks, which, due to the
low weight and density of the carried goods,
rarely have an issue with weight limits.
So, given that most trucks look like this,
with just the bare bones of comforts, most
of the facilities truckers need are located
in the places where they sleep—truck stops.
These dot large countries like the US with
remarkable frequency, centered primarily along
highways and other common trucking routes.
They might look like large gas stations, but
they offer far more.
Truck cabs typically don’t have bathrooms
or showers, so they almost always have those.
They also don’t have laundry facilities,
so truck stops often have those.
Some will also have banks, barbers, chiropractors,
dentists, dog groomers, and more.
This is all because, once truckers are on
the road, they’re in the system, and they
can’t really leave it until they’re back
at their origin.
One can’t just drive into a city and park
to do some shopping in a semi-truck, both
practically and, in some cases, legally.
While truckers might travel more miles in
a year than anyone else, the world, for them,
while on the job, is limited to the roads,
truck-stops, and few other facilities catering
to them.
That’s why services like dentists at truck
stops are far from novelties.
They’re crucial fixtures of a life on the
road.
Truck drivers only make money when they’re
moving.
Overwhelmingly, they are paid per mile meaning
the time during which they are legally mandated
to rest is unpaid.
Not only that, but time off actually loses
money.
The whole game is an economic puzzle.
Trucks need power to run AC, heat, or electronics
while stationary—all of which drivers typically
need when they’re stopped.
Therefore, often, drivers leave their trucks
idling overnight which burns about 0.8 gallons
or 3 liters of diesel per hour.
At current prices, a 10-hour overnight stop
would burn about $20 of diesel which, multiplied
by hundreds of nights per year per driver,
is a significant cost and an even greater
environmental burden.
In addition, this idling adds wear and tear
to the engine, and counts against a truck’s
warranty.
Until recently, there really wasn’t an alternative,
except for sleeping without AC or heat, but
under increased pressure to improve its environmental
footprint, the trucking industry has implemented
innovations such as auxiliary power units—smaller,
more efficient generators—electric plug-ins
at truck stops, or even ducts installed to
the windows when stopped to provide climate
control.
This economic calculation extends beyond stops.
It also deals with optimizing the miles covered
while following the laws.
In the US, the rule is that one can drive
up to 11 hours, over an overall period of
14 hours, and then must rest for 10 hours.
Assuming an average speed of 60 miles per
hour, that means a truck can essentially travel
660 miles per day.
Therefore, a cross-country trip from Los Angeles
to New York would take about four and a half
days.
The drivers themselves are paid per mile so
all they want to do is maximize their speed
during the 11 hours of daily driving time.
The consumer, though—whoever’s paying
for the transport of the product in the back—cares
about how fast it gets to them overall.
Therefore, truckers have devised a system
to move freight faster.
The rules just say that drivers have to rest
for ten hours in their cab—it doesn’t
say that the trucks have to be stationary.
Drivers will therefore team up so that while
one drives, the other sleeps, and vice versa.
A team of drivers, which is often made up
of a married couple, can therefore drive 22
hours per day, covering 1,320 miles.
That means that they could make the Los Angeles
to New York trip in just two days.
Consumers will pay a premium for the speed,
and therefore trucking companies will pay
more per mile.
In addition, having less stopped time means
that the truck, which costs quite a lot, is
being used more efficiently.
This team system is all-around a win for everyone,
assuming one can find a pair of people that
will tolerate spending their lives cooped
up in a truck cab together.
Truckers, almost certainly, are a dying breed,
though.
The future of freight transport will undoubtably
center around self-driving trucks and the
technology for these is very close to ready
for prime-time.
Right now, multiple companies are at the point
where their trucks are traveling autonomously,
with drivers behind the wheel to intervene
if needed.
These are essentially autopilot systems, similar
to Tesla’s, that aid the driver and reduce
fatigue.
Soon, though, with more proven technology
and legal authority to do so, this will likely
advance to autonomous convoys.
In this system, one driver would sit behind
the wheel of a lead truck, which might also
drive autonomously, and then a series of autonomous,
human-less trucks would follow behind.
This way, there is still a human that can
assist with mechanical issues or unforeseen
road conditions, but the freight to driver
ratio increases dramatically.
This will, of course, reduce the number of
truckers needed, but then, after this phase,
the industry will undoubtably advance to fully
autonomous trucks.
At first, this will likely just be on dedicated
routes—for example, a company might deploy
these on uncomplicated routes from one warehouse
to another, both being close to a highway.
Autonomous driving on highways is relatively
easy since roads conditions are standardized
and predictable.
Autonomous city driving is much more complicated,
so human drivers might still be needed for
the start and end of journeys.
What fully autonomous driving could do, though,
is allow a truck to continue moving on the
highway while a driver rests in the back,
allowing essentially continuous driving without
having to deal with working hour limits.
This, along with a convoy system, could increase
the cost efficiency of trucking dramatically,
as the human drivers represent a significant
cost.
An average trucker’s pay is about 35 cents
per mile, meaning that cutting out that cost
entirely would reduce the cost of a Los Angeles
to New York trip, for example, by almost $1,000.
It is for this reason why so many companies
are pursuing autonomous trucks.
Of course, the other major cost in trucking
is fuel, so companies are also trying to innovate
in that space.
Concurrent to the deployment of autonomous
trucks is a likely shift into the use of electric
trucks.
Tesla, for example, is developing its own
semi truck.
They claim its energy consumption will be
about two kilowatt hours per mile.
The US’ average energy cost is about 10
cents per kilowatt hour, which translates
to an energy cost of about 20 cents per mile.
Typical internal combustion semi-trucks have
an efficiency of about 6 miles per gallon
so, at current diesel prices, that would translate
to a cost of about 40 cents per mile.
Halving a trucking company’s energy prices
is certainly an intriguing proposition, which
is why many consider the Tesla semi so promising.
At those prices, if a truck goes driverless,
meaning no salary costs, the variable cost
of a cross-country, Los Angeles to New York
run would be just $550.
To be able to haul tens of thousands of pounds
of goods from door to door across the country
for just hundreds of dollars would result
in a paradigm shift in the freight world.
There are certainly disadvantages, such as
the high battery pack weight that reduces
cargo capacity, but it is clear that electric
trucks will play some role in the industry
regardless in the near future.
This role will likely be concentrated in shorter
routes, rather than long-haul ones, but this
is still a significant enough subset of the
industry that electric trucks have the potential
for significant disruption.
Right now, there is an strange duality where
truckers are so crucial the running of a modern
economy that the world is working to replace
them.
We can’t live without them right now, so
we’re finding a way to.
In the future, though, the job of a trucker
will undoubtably be another victim of an increasingly
modernized world.
Another aspect of an increasingly modernized
world is clearly more people working from
home and with that, it’s more important
than ever to be sure that you’re using the
internet securely.
ExpressVPN can play a crucial component in
that for you.
They assure that 100% of the data transferred
between your device and the internet is encrypted
therefore providing a layer of protection
for everything you do online.
This is important because, for example, in
the US, internet service providers can legally
sell your data to ad companies and in the
UK and Australia, they keep logs of your internet
activity for years.
In addition, you can route your traffic through
any country to be extra sure it’s safe against
government surveillance, or even just to get
access to a bigger selection of online entertainment.
I’ve personally used ExpressVPN for years,
far before they offered to sponsor the channel,
and have found that their simplicity and reliability
makes them, definitively, the best VPN.
The best bit is, you can try ExpressVPN with
three months free by going to expressvpn.com/wendover,
and you’ll be supporting the channel while
you’re at it.